I'm Shannon bream I'm Bill hemmer I'm
Kennedy and this is the Fox News Rundown
Wednesday February 22nd 2023 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal recent studies and
standardized test scores have some
warning about the effects of pandemic
related learning loss and while some
school districts are taking it seriously
the long-term impacts may hurt our
economy from what I've seen school
districts are dramatically under
estimating what it's going to take to
allow students to catch up I'm Dave
Anthony
it's Ash Wednesday
the most visited day of the year for
Christians visiting churches and why is
that
we receive a very visible symbol
of our identity and of our belief and
I'm Dr Ben Carson I've got the final
word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
last fall we got the nation's report
card on standardized test scores from
across the country and they were in a
word disappointing fourth and eighth
grade scores dropped especially when it
came to math we've never seen this this
magnitude of a draw particularly uh in
eighth grade mathematics it is jarring
it is sobering it is deeply disturbing
Roberto Rodriguez is an assistant
secretary at the Department of Education
and he participated in a national
assessment of educational progress
Roundtable late last year now we have a
new study one that assessed learning
loss in 15 countries it concluded
students on average lost about a third
of a year of instruction a recent U.S
based study released by the education
recovery scorecard found third through
eighth graders in the U.S lost more like
half a year of learning Rodriguez says
there are ways to work on this they've
doled out billions to each state in
American Rescue plan Elementary and
secondary school emergency relief funds
but now the burden is on school board
superintendent its principals and
teachers to implement a plan and recover
from the educational losses so the
latest study that I read was out of
Education week and I believe I read that
last week that said as a general
approximation we're looking at one third
of a school year lost to our students
from the pandemic year and moving
forward Beth Crider is the Peoria County
Regional superintendent in Illinois
overseeing 18 school districts but it's
more than just the academic loss right
it's it's attendance it's social
emotional learning and the mental health
struggles that we're seeing all of that
combined is that we have a lot of work
to do in the public school system to
recover and move forward post pandemic
so we have some strategies that we're
putting in place and the evidence is
suggesting that we need accelerated
after school programming we need
accelerated summer school programming
and then we need to wrap all of that in
mental health supports and so there's a
lot that we can do to mitigate some of
that learning loss and then accelerate
the learning is that something that you
can mandate or is that something that
you just say hey parents if you do want
your kids to you know brush up let's do
you know enroll them in summer school or
how do you sort of implement this in
terms of either mandating it or just
saying we're offering it that's a yes
and so you can mandate it for some
learning loss for kids absolutely but as
school districts if we want to get into
some of that funding the Esser funding
the covid funding if you will we were
required to write for after-school
programming and summer school
programming into those dollars or we did
not receive them so that's a major
Carrick for your school districts to go
after those dollars and bring them to
their local school districts is to have
those things available for their
families yeah we keep hearing that money
is available there's some of the extra
American Rescue plan money left over
you're saying you if you want some of
that you have to account for it you have
to ask for it and have it doled out to
you and you have to prove that you need
it and what you have to have a business
plan essentially absolutely I run the
Alternative High School here for Peoria
County for kids that haven't been
successful in their home high school and
when I wrote for those dollars it was
very specific by percentiles of how much
money had to go to those things so it is
written into the plan wow so finally
then it sounds like you guys have have a
plan that you want to have implemented
what then would you tell parents who
maybe don't necessarily see this as a
big deal or aren't recognizing you know
learning loss in in their homes
especially those families that maybe
don't have money for private tutors I
mean we you know what would you you know
tell parents to do if they want to help
their kids with this learning loss and
and reinforce that it's real and and
it's happening it's harmful
well let's start with the sense of
urgency and it's around developmental
Milestones kids are naturally supposed
to go through certain things in middle
school high school right so what we're
seeing what teachers are reporting is
that a ninth grader is showing up more
like a seventh grader developmentally
the sense of urgency is there we have
kindergartners that are showing up that
maybe have not been around their peers
of any age because they were in their
homes for so long so there are those
developmental Milestones kids need to be
hitting and they need to be in social
situations they need to be back in
school full-time and they need to be
getting those supports because without
them those delays are going to continue
and we will see those delays continuing
throughout their lifespan unless we get
a hold of those now and early
intervention is always best it turns out
not all learning loss is equal Thomas
Kane The Faculty director of the center
for Education policy research at Harvard
has been studying the covet related
School interruptions and found that
students from lower income homes have
struggled more finding the quarter of
schools with highest shares of students
receiving Federal lunch subsidies missed
two-thirds of a year of math learning
while the quarter of schools with the
fewest low-income students lost just
two-fifths of a year it's likely to have
been due to a number of different
factors number one higher income parents
were more likely to be in jobs that
allowed them to work from home and as a
result parents were more available for
you know monitoring students learning
online another factor is likely to have
been you know Broadband access another
would simply be access to a quiet space
at home uh like having your own bedroom
to be able to do your lessons or a desk
where you could sit at to do your
lessons rather than being gathered
around a you know a kitchen table with
your you know your brothers and sisters
all trying to do lessons online at the
same time I I think there were a number
of different factors that likely played
a role what should we do then right now
if if learning loss is real and damaging
then then how how do we fix this because
you can't just keep you know a bunch of
six to 16 year olds in school for longer
days I mean they're you know your brain
can't absorb everything all at once
um this would obviously have to happen
over time this whole ketchup process
right so what do we do
so Jessica that is a terrific question
and so first of all your your listeners
should know that these declines in
achievement means students have lost a
lot like so we've looked in the past at
what happened in states that saw big
increases in achievement and when uh
achievement was increasing we saw that
earnings were Rising college going Rose
arrest rates declined and now that we've
seen achievement fall based on that
history we predict there's going to be
about a 1.6 percent decline in students
lifetime earnings now 1.6 percent
doesn't sound like a gigantic loss but
it's about twenty thousand dollars per
student uh over the course of their
lifetime now from what I've seen school
districts are dramatically under
estimating what it's going to take to to
allow students to catch up so just for
you know your listeners I've looked at
the research on the effects of things
like summer learning the effects of
tutors double dose math so you're right
it's hard to dramatically lengthen the
school day but there has been research
on the effects of providing students
with an extra period of math or an extra
period of reading so here would be the
kind of program that that would be
necessary to help students catch up so
provide high dosage tutors to 10 percent
of students where high dosage tutoring
means a student is getting a tutor for
three times a week for the whole school
year many districts are rolling out
providing tutors but not nearly as high
dosage as three times per week for the
whole school year but suppose we could
do that for 10 percent of students
suppose we did summer school and we got
75 percent of students to show up first
summer school suppose that we provided
an extra period of math instruction to
30 percent of students and suppose on
top of all that we extended the school
year by two and a half weeks no district
is doing anything like that and yet if
you added up the effect sizes for all of
those interventions it would add up to
about a half a Year's worth of growth
and a lot of districts have lost more
like a whole year or a year and a half
so school districts need to be doing
much more and the reason why I mention
that is districts are sitting on about
190 billion dollars in federal aid that
they received since the beginning of the
pandemic and those dollars need to be
spent by September 24 and unless
districts start to rethink how they're
using that money and and rethink their
recovery plans that money will have been
spent and students will still not have
caught up that's a really important
point that if you do have the dollars
because this I was thinking as you were
talking this would this would take
additional funding and if you're saying
the funding is largely there that seems
like that would be the most obvious way
to put it to use let me ask you just
briefly a couple more questions one um
this notion of dollar loss I'm seeing
this economist from the Hoover
institution he looked at this data too
and he said he he estimated seventy
thousand dollars of loss and income for
impacted kids over the course of their
lives and 28 trillion dollars in losses
to the economy this Century uh because
of this learning loss are you I don't
know how we come up with these numbers
at such an early stage and forecast that
but I I think many would see that and
I've spoken to a couple of people just
average people about this topic and
they're they're very skeptical that
we're already concluding fiscal loss due
to learning loss so as I said what we
did was we looked back and saw okay so
in the states that saw large increases
in the National assessment of
educational progress during the 90s what
happened to the incomes of those people
who graduated from school in those
States and there were huge increases in
earnings and so like just based on that
historical fact we're saying okay well
what's likely to happen from the
declines that other research that you're
citing from Stanford that's using a
different set of data but basically
saying okay well what do we know about
the relationship between students
achievement on end of year test scores
and earnings in college going uh later
in life and you know everybody has found
over the last 40 years that we've been
looking at this a relationship between
Higher Achievement on these tests and
and better labor market opportunities so
it stands to reason that if just given
the relationships in the past what would
we expect from such a large decline
finally I just want your thoughts and
this is this is sort of a broader topic
but it might be related we hear a lot
about how generally we're not educating
our kids for the 21st century you know
companies have long been complaining now
for years about a skills Gap that people
just aren't prepared for the jobs of
today how do we move through learning
loss that's pandemic related and sort of
reconcile that with the sense that even
before the pandemic kids were maybe not
getting the education that we we need
for our economy so we had been making
progress before the pandemic although it
was slower I think than most folks
wanted you know the black white
achievement Gap had been narrowing
between uh 1990 through 2015 average
achievement in math especially in an
early grades Reading had risen
substantially so we had been making
progress and we lost about 40 percent of
that progress just in three years at
least 40 percent of the progress in
eighth grade math we lost between 2019
and 2022. so yes there were problems
even as of 2019 but those problems just
got a lot worse over the last few years
Professor Tom Kane faculty director at
the center for Education policy research
at Harvard thank you for joining us all
right thanks Jessica
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Dr Ben Carson with your Fox News
commentary coming up
the party is over in Rio
[Music]
Paul has come to a
new one after all the parades and
celebrations and bead tossing
leading up to Mardi Gras are what's also
called Fat Tuesday and this year
revelers could enjoy that without covert
restrictions in New Orleans the 2023
wrecks king of Carnival is Tulane
Professor ludovico fioli I've come to
understand uh the the wonderful good
fortune that being able to congregate
with the community
represents but all of that celebration
is over it's Ash Wednesday a much more
solemn day for Christians a beginning of
Lent a period of purification and
preparation for the great celebration of
Easter Jonathan Morris is a theologian
and Fox News contributor a former priest
one of the days of the year where we see
more religious attendance than any other
day including Easter including Christmas
really it's Ash Wednesday really I would
have thought Christmas Eve and Christmas
Day would be number one by far at least
in the Catholic church as you mentioned
I was a Catholic priest for for many
years so I saw many Ash Wednesday
services in many parts of the country
and around the world the most visited
day of the year for Christians visiting
churches and why is that we receive a
very visible symbol of our identity and
of our belief it's it's a way of saying
I want to be a part of something but why
what is the ash physically what is the
symbolism sure so the ash is think of
Ash as as a symbol of death back to the
Earth remember the story of Genesis and
the creation of man and woman man coming
forth from the ground and that we are
temporal we're going back to the ashes
we're going back to the Earth and that's
of course a very very Vivid but also a
very I would say morbid and in the
healthiest of ways a healthy reminder
that I better get my life straight
because time is short okay so why does
it begin lint why why does that start
the lent season well it goes back to the
the example of Jesus who went out into
the desert before he began his public
Ministry and that's really what lent is
it's a 40 plus days of purification in
preparation for the beginning of our
Christian Journey the faithful asked
or expected to give something up for
lend correct yes in different Christian
Traditions there are different
invitations of what we can do during
Lent giving up something doing something
hard that that purifies us that reminds
us that just giving in to every whim is
not necessarily going to bring us to
happiness that's one right another one
would be almsgiving it's saying the
things that I have right the things that
I own yes they're objectively mine
legally but there's not absolute
ownership in the Christian worldview
that I might have a hundred dollars in
my pocket but that hundred dollars also
is meant for the good of others okay to
donate yes yes give to give
um that's also convenient for churches I
think so I'm not sure where the origin
are that's fair but I think it is a
healthy thing to give right and then
third is prayer right it to increase our
prayer life to with God to converse with
God to deepen our relationship with him
through prayer but these days fewer
people are connecting with God in church
back in 1972
92 percent of Americans in a Pew
research survey identified as Christian
in 2020
that number's down to 64 percent nearly
a third say they're religiously
unaffiliated
the other six percent identify as Jewish
Muslim Hindu or Buddhist LifeWay
research reports in 2019 4 500
Protestant churches closed Across
America a first in the years it's been
tracking that a trend believed to have
accelerated during the covet pandemic
and LifeWay also reports in 2017 it did
a survey of 18 to 22 year olds who had
attended church regularly while in high
school seven in ten of them stopped
going
but Jonathan Morris says that does not
worry him God has not been diminished
even if our faith or our practice of
religion has diminished in other words
nothing really really important has
changed okay God is still in my belief
Christian belief God is just as much God
he is just as much an all-loving
all-powerful providential being as he
was before the pandemic and 50 years ago
and even in the kind of golden age of
Christianity in America we're not going
to church because we don't believe as
much our parents went to church because
they had to go to church or they felt
guilty if they didn't go to church
what's going to happen now
there will not be a major change in this
shift to my belief until we suffer
deeply as a country or individually so
we have to have
a Calamity of some kind for people to
turn more to God for answers think about
after 9 11 churches were filled
think about major moments in our life I
prayed more deeply when I was going
through moments of existential crisis
than when things were going well so when
things go badly for us as a country
during times of war God forbid during
times of a Calamity Financial or
economical economic crisis God forbid
that's when people will start asking the
big questions that our grandparents
asked there will be a Great Awakening I
think it will be instigated or generated
by suffering
one reason that people cite a lessening
of faith
people think that the church let's say
Catholic church right that it's it's not
keeping up with modern times the beliefs
people have whether it's uh abortion or
marriage or contraception that the
church is behind and and people think
that they just can't go to the church
anymore they don't trust it child sexual
abuse Scandal the whole thing that's
happened with over the last couple of
decades do you think that the church
needs to change
the church doesn't need to adapt to
modern times in other words change
itself so that it's just like everything
else just the opposite we need to change
with the times in order to keep up with
God in order to make sure that the
teachings that that we are transmitting
are as Jesus would teach the people of
our day
Jesus said love others as I have loved
you
that's the that's the big that's the big
challenge how do we love other people as
Jesus would love them
a parent that is not bringing a child
into churches or into Faith as they grow
up are they
are they robbing that child of something
or are they
depriving the child of the opportunity
for faith
I remember when I was a priest down at
Old Saint Pat's cathedral in the Soho
section of New York City which is a very
hip area a very young demographic the
average person in the neighborhood who
lived there was probably about 25 years
old and many of them told me
kind of ticked off at my parents and I
said I thought you know maybe I don't
know who knows why they were ticked off
and one after another after another told
me because they never
gave me an opportunity
to really know my faith and to come to a
relationship with God they did this not
because they hated me because but
because they wanted to allow me to
choose and I remember one saying to me
you know what if they had done the same
thing with math or science Hey listen we
don't want to we don't want to brainwash
you so we're not going to let give you
any math lessons any science lessons
we're going to let you discover it on
your own
and and in the in these cases of these
young people actually maybe the path
that their parents chose actually worked
for them but my guess is that there are
hundreds and thousands of others like
them whose parents were saying the same
things either like philosophically we
don't want to brainwash you or else just
and this is probably more likely just a
little bit lazy
I always found it interesting with a
religion it's where you were born and
where you live in the world that decides
how necessarily what faith you're
exposed to when you when you grow up in
America of course most people would be
the Christian faith if they're going to
church not Judaism or Buddhism or
Hinduism India would be different
you'd be different if you were in other
parts of Asia it would be different if
you grew up in the Middle East
kids don't say okay here are the five
religions what do you think fits you
best some people would use that as a a
reason why we shouldn't be Christian or
whatever it is that we our parents were
um we are responsible to God
and as much as God reveals himself to us
maybe it's a longing for understanding
the life's big questions about eternity
but God is able to because he's so much
bigger than time or place or religion
that he can reveal himself in a way that
then we have to respond or we can we
have an opportunity to respond to so
much much different than Hey listen
Catholicism or Christianity can't be
true because what about those who never
even heard about Christianity because
they were born Muslim I would say the
same thing that Muslim that that Jew
that atheist that
God has not changed if we if we believe
in God God will reveal himself to us in
ways that are inconceivable and we're
only responsible to that truth that
goodness that beauty in as much as it's
been revealed to us but with all the
religions unless you're atheist just
about everybody believes there is some
sort of a higher power right in that
absolutely no matter which one religion
you're you're following yes especially I
would say especially the the
monotheistic uh the great the three
great monotheistic religions uh that you
you spoke of Islam on Judaism
Christianity and if there are other kind
of spiritual belief systems that don't
that don't believe in a personal God is
as we do but yes you're exactly right
Jonathan Morris Theologian Fox News
contributor former priest thanks very
much for joining us my pleasure
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi if
you have an old iPhone laying around it
could be worth some serious cash a first
generation iPhone still in its Factory
sealed box sold for an eye-popping 63
356.40 at an auction on Sunday that's 10
times its original price of 599 dollars
back in 2007. at the time the first
release smartphone featured an
Innovative touchscreen a web browser and
a 2 megapixel camera and eight gigs of
storage it received Time magazine's
invention of the year and quickly became
Apple's best-selling product compare
that to today's Tech with the iPhone 14
Pro's 48 megapixel camera and anywhere
from 128 gigs to a terabyte of storage
the seller of the auction phone Karen
Greene said she got the phone as a gift
but never used it because she didn't
want to switch Wireless carriers so it
sat in its unopened box on her shelf for
12 years but in October green says she
saw an unopened first release iPhone
sold for more than thirty nine thousand
dollars at an earlier auction she says
she's going to use the sixty three
thousand dollars she made to start a
Cosmetic tattoo studio in New Jersey the
buyer hasn't been revealed for the Fox
News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
from the Fox News podcasts Network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from Fox News listen and
download the Fox News hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com read
and review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your Fox News commentary Dr Ben
Carson what's on your mind as we
celebrate Black History Month this
February Americans of all Stripes would
do well to remember that black history
is not something apart from American
history but simply another part of our
great National story
unfortunately in years past Black
History Month has been used as a cloud
to divide the American people based on
race all the sins from America's past
are highlighted radical anti-American
figures are elevated extreme ideologies
like critical race Theory are pushed on
our children and some are even
attempting to redefine the very date of
America's Foundation
this year I wanted to change the
narrative
by taking this opportunity to highlight
just one lesser-known African-American
hero from our history and share his
story as an example of patriotism
and unity
Peter Salem was born into slavery in
Framingham Massachusetts in 1750 and
lived there until age 25 when he was
emancipated so he could enlist as a
Massachusetts Minuteman
as a soldier Salem fought in the very
first engagements of the Revolutionary
War through his participation in the
Battle of Lexington and Concord with
Colonel John Nixon's fifth Massachusetts
Regiment which included several other
African-American soldiers later that
year Salem fought in the Battle of
Bunker Hill
and was widely credited with firing the
shot that killed British Major John
Pitcairn which gave the fledgling
continental army a much needed morale
boost early in the war
Salem received an accommodation from the
Massachusetts general court for his
bravery at Bunker Hill and then
continued his service by real listening
with the fourth Continental regiment
After the Revolutionary War Salem built
a home in Leicester Massachusetts and
struggled to get by while working as a
weaver gardener
and chair repairman struggling to earn a
living
at the age of 66 Salem died in obscurity
and a poor house back in Framingham
Salem like Christmas addicts Phyllis
Wheatley Titus Coburn and so many other
black Patriots of the American
Revolution stood up for the cause of
Independence because they understood the
very promise America represents though
we failed to perfectly live up to those
ideals at the time our nation was
founded
today America Remains the land of
equality Liberty and opportunity for all
our past isn't perfect
but our story Tells A Tale of a people
valiantly standing up for what they
believe in
our founding principles and the promises
they hold have allowed each of us to
grow up in a place where we are free to
pursue our own American Dream
as our past shows us good men and women
of every age need to defend these
American values with courage and
strength Ronald Reagan reminded us that
freedom is never more than one
generation away from Extinction and it
is up to all of us to keep the promise
of America alive for our children our
children's children and their children
after that
Peter Salem answered that call as did
many others whose stories are known but
to God
I think that's something worth
reflecting on this Black History Month
this is Dr Ben Carson
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad-free on
Fox News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
I'm Guy Benson join me weekdays at 3 P.M
Eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the Fox News app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com